hi i'm jorg graf from the university of
connecticut
i'm a microbiologist and i study
microbiomes in different
animal systems and also in the built
environment of the
aquaculture and today i will be talking
to you about
insights into aquatic biofilm dynamics
by high throughput identification of
bacterial isolates
and full-length 16s rna gene surveys
what you see here on this slide is a
it's a raceway of a commercial trout
farm and where the arrow is pointing
is where you where there's a biofilm and
you can see a fluorescent in situ
hybridization image
of one of such biofilms and we're
interested
in studying these biofilms because
they harbor pathogen fish pathogenic
bacteria
so specifically flavor bacteria are
important
pathogens in the aquaculture setting
flavor bacterium columnar and flavor
bacterium cyclophyllum
cause major disease outbreaks in
aquaculture facilities worldwide
and in some locations like the one that
we visit
these infections reoccur on an annual
basis
and they lead to very high mortality and
so
it is really important to figure out
where these pathogens coming from
where are they hiding and other ways
that we can prevent these recurring
infections
without having to resort to adding
antibiotics
potential reservoirs for these bacteria
include the biofilms that
form on the surfaces either in the pipes
or in the raceways themselves
they can also result from having
infected
fish come into the raceways and then
they serve as a pine sort
of point source and they spread rapidly
to the other fish in these dense
environments
and so understanding the dynamics of
biofilm development
is really important to figure out how to
prevent these diseases
and provide new intervention
opportunities
and so the goals of our project are
to to study these reoccurring flavor
bacterium columnar and flavor vacuum
cycle filament factions
that occur in this this farm in in fuel
idaho
especially inside a hatch house where
the young fish that are most susceptible
uh are living and grown and to determine
the role of these biofilms in these
reoccurring infections
and we are also interested in culturing
autophagonous bacteria so bacteria from
the same source
that can inhibit the growth of flavor
bacterium luminara and flavor bacterium
cyclophyllum so that perhaps we can
end up using them as a probiotic to stop
these infections
this is our sampling site
it's the snake river in idaho and
one place that we visit is uh the source
of the water that goes to the farm which
is
a canyon and then within the from the
canyon the water gets pumped
to the farm and there are these biofilms
that you can see
forming on the rocks in this in the
creek in this canyon
and we all we took samples from those
biofilms
then this water enters the hatch house
where the
fry and and the young fish are grown up
until they can be transferred
to the adult raceways and here you see a
picture also of
testerman a graduate student in my lab
was instrumental in performing this work
and then these are what the adult
raceways look like
and i one want to go over the standard
procedures that we use in this study and
one of them is the
standard v4 processing workflow
and on the left hand side we begin
with the sampling method so we can
either connect the swabs from surfaces
by using
a sterile swabs or we can also
get samples from the fish dissecting
them
and or taking swabs of them we also
filter the water
we use a two micrometer pre-filter
that's shown in the bottom right in the
left panel
or we can also you and we then
subsequently use
stereo vx filter that is a 0.2 micron
filter
for each sample we filtered about 6
liters of water
from those samples we then use a dna
extraction kit
that we can automate using a kaya cube
it's a bead based approach and after
isolating
and quantifying the dna the pcr amplify
in this case the v4 region of the 16s
rna in triplicate
then we process these samples further we
pool them
clean them up and sequence them on an
aluminum ic
and then the data analysis is done
using chime 2 and data 2.
we also use full length 16s rna
sample processing and here's the
workflow for that for this we used
either samples from fish or also swabs
and we're using a commercially available
kit from a company called shoreline
biome
that's a startup company in connecticut
where we're located
and we use the dna extraction kit
and after that we use the dna
pcr amplification kit for the v1 to v9
region of the 16s rna
and then we sequence it on a sql compact
sql 2 from pac bio
the sql 2 gives us a lot more throughput
than the sql does
we then use the company's initial
program for analysis the program for
analysis sb analyzer
and their database athena and after that
we switch over to
data2 and also chime 2 for the
subsequent data analysis
and here's an example of how we
provide the information this is an image
of a raceway and then you have a pie
chart that shows you the microbial the
composition of the microbial community
of a baffle swab
baffles are the the white inserts that
slow down the
flow rate of the water and you can see
in blue
would be alpha proteobacteria so the
area of that pie chart
corresponds to the relative abundance of
alpha proteobacteria in blue of
bacteroidea
and then in in
an orange of pectoroidia and then in
gray of gamma proteobacteria and so you
kind of can get a sense of the
composition of the microbial community
in these raceways
and so the water entering is shown then
here on the left hand side on the top
the pie chart shows you what's in the
pre-filter caught by the pre-filter
and then on the bottom you show what's
basically planktonic so these are 0.2
micron
captured microorganisms and you can see
that
there are these uh oxophotobacteria that
are present
in the on the pre-filter that are then
basically absent uh
on the pancreatic sample showing that
they're different communities depending
on the size that you sample
we can then also look at the entire
community that is present on the
surfaces so these will be biofilm
samples
and you can see that the distribution of
the colors is very different
in the in the pie charts in the center
they're dominated by blue
so that would be alpha proteobacteria
and then also bacteroidea
and gamma proteobacteria so those are
the most abundant attacks are in here
and what we're now interested in doing
is
trying to see how does the microbial
community in these biofilms on the
surface walls
change as the fish in the in these
raceways age
and so we're going to now focus on
studying these wall swabs
and for this tar and i collected a whole
series of wall swabs from
raceways they contain very young fish
and then also older fish
and we're depicting these data here on
an nmds plant
on nmds plants when two each
dart represents microbial community when
two dots are close together
these communities are very similar to
each other and when they're far apart
they're very different from each other
using the break curtis distance matrix
measure
on the left hand side in blue these are
microbiome samples from the wall of
raceways harboring very young fish and
you see an image of those little fish
fry on the top of that and they all
cluster
very close together and
the circle around them shows you the
confidence interval
so they form one distinct community
structure
then in the middle in green we have
young fish so these are a little bit
bigger as you can see they actually look
much more like a real fish
and on the far right in red we have then
what we call the mature or the older
fish that are ready to be moved out to
the adult
raceways and each age group has
clusters very nicely and they form a
statistically significant distinct
microbial community
and so you can see that as the biofilm
ages or the
fish age in the raceway and by
the walls are not cleaned in between and
so the microbial community changes in
composition
we can now take a look uh to a closer
look at these microbial communities
and see how the composition
what the composition is like and for
that we use bar graphs
where each color represents a different
taxon
and then the height of the color within
a bar graph shows you the relative
abundance i begin on the left hand side
here showing you
what the community composition looks
like in a
raceway that contains the youngest fish
and you can see how
these two green bars actually represent
two different
taxa one of them is the pollution
and the other one is pseudomonas and uh
please
remember pseudomonas later on in the
talk
it will come back so you can see that in
the young raceways
pseudomonas is actually pretty abundant
of the youngest fish and then when we
look at the raceways containing
the younger fish which now shows up you
can
the pseudomonas is sometimes present but
usually it's not as abundant it
really the taxon that is mostly found in
the race with the youngest fish
but hydrogen faga and also noble
sphingium for example have
increased in the relative abundance you
begin to see a shift in the microbial
community
you also see that the different
the number of different colors has
increased and this shows us that the
micro
complexity of the microbial community is
increasing
and the same is true when we move on
to the adult race place which is now
shown on the far right
and you have different taxa that begin
to increase in abundance that were less
abundant
in the earlier stages so the maturation
of the microbial community
we can also then begin to compare this
data
by using full length versus
b4 sequencing and on these the next
series of bar graphs
you will see the full length sequences
first and then
followed by the b4 sequences and
what we observed is that we got
quite a different distribution depending
on
which sequencing approach we use and
this also holds up when we look at
more samples so here you see the
youngest microbial communities you can
see that the fir
that the first bar is very different
than the second bar and this pattern
continues
and this is now when we look at a whole
subset
and we think that these differences are
due to two different things
it has been shown by other people that
depending on which
primers you use for amplifying the 16s
rna
you introduce different primer biases
and so this will then lead to the
differential amplification
of some tax or over other taxes so one
cannot really compare
microbial communities from the d4 region
to a v1 to b3 region
or a full length region simply due to
the primary bias
and another thing is that we use the
different dna extraction
that is not a b base but but a different
lysis
approach base that is actually very good
at also lysing gram positive bacteria
and spores and so you could introduce a
biased artery
and so while we get different community
structures i want to point out
the differences that we can see
using the full length in in contrast to
the v4 sequences
and this is shown when we focus on this
one group of bacteria right here the
protobacter
and in the bar graph on the left hand
side you see
how many different sequences or sequence
variants we
get returned by doing the b4 regions
about 200
while we get over a thousand
amplified sequence variants when back
when we do the full length 16s sequences
so we get a much more fine-tuned insight
into the microbial community when we can
use full length sequencing
and this might allow us to discover new
patterns and
identify species that we could not
otherwise identify
we were also able to detect flavor
bacterium columnar reeds
and we could quantify them and then
determine that
in the youngest and young raceways
very few of the samples were actually
positive so in the youngest only one out
of eight was positive
and in the young three out of 18 were
positive
and they contained very low numbers of
flavor bacteria corner reads when
normalized to 10 000 weeds
and that would be less than one when we
looked at the mature
raceways and we saw that 10 out of 12
were positive
and the count had increased to 3.5 so it
looks like as the
biofilm in the raceway matures you also
get colonization
by pathogenic flavor bacteria
and in the diseased uh in a in a raceway
with diseased fish
you could actually see that all of the
samples were positive and the kelp was
even higher even though
the causative agent that they identified
was not a flavor bacterium
so how can we now begin to control the
presence and abundance of these
pathogenic flavor bacteria in these
raceways without having to resort to
added antibiotics so
our idea was to culture bacteria from
this local environment
and then see if we can identify some
bacteria
it might be able to inhibit the growth
of pathogenic bacteria
so it's basically a probiotic for the
built environment
so we collected swab samples from
biofilms either in the raceway or
in the canyon where the water is coming
from and
plated them on different types of media
trying to including a media that have
been shown to
allow the growth of many aquatic
bacteria and also a low nutrient media
and on this plate you can see all the
different colors and all of the
different sizes of the bacteria that we
could grow
on this raceway from this raceway wall
the approach then would be to take swabs
then we swab the plate
put the swab then on an argo plate and
cover the whole area
we then do a dilution of that and we
incubate them either at 15 degrees or 25
degrees
then after the bacteria have grown up
we treat them for isolation and then we
will subculture those again to get pure
cultures and those are
stored and frozen at minus 80 degrees
for further use
because some of these bacteria grow up
very slowly we actually
kept them in a in an incubator for
several weeks
and checking them regularly and
isolating more and more colonies trying
to get the slow growing bacteria as well
the next step then
is to freeze them away and we got over
900 different isolates that we wanted to
study further
and then the next aspect was to see if
any of these would then inhibit
the growth of pathogenic bacteria and so
we inoculated the bacteria in these 96
well deep well plates
and from those plates
we would then in these plates we would
grow up the bacteria
until we had a nice pusher and that
would be either one or two days
at 19 degrees and we would prepare
these large argo plates on which we
would spread
one of these four pathogens so plano
bacterium narrative
bacterium cyclophyllum nissin heracary
or aeromonas salmonecida which are all
common fish pathogens and then using an
ep
motion we would spot bacteria
onto these lawns that would form
and so we would take a 196 well plate
and spot 48 of those
isolates on one plate and the other 48
on a different plate so that we get
nicer spatial separation
and then you let them grow up and
you look for zones of inhibition and
here you see now an image of one of
these other plates after
48 hours and you see a
light gray film and that is actually the
flavor bacterium that's growing up on
the arga plate
and then the different colored circles
in the center
are these colonies that formed
where we had spotted the different
cultures that we had
collected in the drug farm and now the
goal is to look for zones of inhibition
and so take a look at this plate and try
to see if you can detect
zones of inhibition and and how many do
you actually see
so the most obvious one is down here in
the right hand corner now circled with
yellow
there's one that formed a really large
zone of inhibition
and so the bacteria that form this
colony
seem to secrete a compound that is able
to kill off this flavor bacterium
but there are actually two more zones of
inhibition that you can
pick up and you see them now circled in
the yellow circle right there
and so here you have on this one plate
out of these 48 strains we got
the three different isolates that
inhibit the growth
able to inhibit the growth of flavor
bacterium columnar
and so of the 562 isolates that we
screened
we found a 35 isolates that inhibited at
least
one pathogen so that's basically six
percent of the pathogens
uh inhibit six percent of the isolates
that we screened inhibited at least
one of these pathogens uh 18 out of the
35
actually inhibited two or more pathogens
and five of them
three pathogens and so we have now a
collection of strains that we would like
to analyze further
and the first thing is we want to
identify what these bacteria are
and for that we returned to the
shoreline biome
b1 through b9 kit we used it for the dna
extractions
they're using the dna print in 96 well
format
so when we grew them up we could go
straight from the 96 well plate that we
grew them up in
to the dna prep plate and after
isolating the dna we would then put it
on the bar-coded pcr plate
and then we had six different plates but
they all have the same
96 barcodes and so what we did is
we used six different smart belts that
had different barcodes
and that was done at the university of
maryland for us at their sequencing
center
and so they prepared the six different
smart bells
that gave us then six different barcodes
one unique barcode for each
pcr plate they were all pooled and then
they were sequenced on a single
sequel to run
we got the data back and we got
millions of reads back and then
if you now look how many reads we got
for each
of the smart bells and for each of the
samples we got over 4
000 reads for each one of our 96
samples and so this gives us a really
deep insight
into the 16s sequences that we get from
there and so we could have actually
multiplex uh you know gone
to 12 plates for example so
we have a very good depth it also allows
us to detect contamination
or if we have two isolates in one plate
we identified them by using the
sv analyzer and data ii and after that
the asvs were incorporated into chime 2
and there we used the green gene
reference data set initially
to identify them and then more recently
we used the silver and
database and that actually gave us a
more detailed higher resolution
identification
and so then for each genus we took all
of the
sequin asbs that we got back and all of
the 16s
rna sequences of the type strains and
constructed phylogenetic trees
that we could take a closer look at the
phylogenetic relationships and the
identification
here's the overall taxonomic breakdown
so we cultured bacteria belonging to 22
different families and 48 different
genera
the most common genera included
pseudomonas pheromonous
flavor bacterium and a cynicobacter
and the most the ice the isolates that
inhibited the bacteria most of them
actually belong to pseudomonas
and so if you think back now to the
earlier slide where i showed you the
changes in the microbial community of
the raceway as the fish
grew the young the biofilms in the
raceways containing the youngest fish
actually had the most
number of flavor of pseudomonas and then
later on they were less abundant
so these pseudomonads seem to produce
antibiotics
but they're not that abundant in the
older biofilms
here you can now see i'm going to show
you a couple of phylogenetic trees
and i begin with the zoom in to kind of
explain it to you a little bit
and so in the center you see the
phylogenetic tree
in blue are the type strains and in red
are the asvs that you
found and they actually represent
most likely novel species because
they're quite different
from the known type strains and then
when you go to the
outer circles the red color and the blue
color there again
indicate an asb versus a type strain and
then the squares
show you which species of pathogens each
isolate
inhibited so here
you have a bacterium an isolate that is
closely related
uh to a
pseudomonas and destiny and that one
actually inhibited you yosemia rockery
and flavor bacterium cyclophyllum okay
and so this way we can kind of
depict how many different bacteria we
cultured and how diverse the microbial
community is that they came from
and i'm going to zoom out now to show
you how many different
types of pseudomonas we cultured and how
far they're spread out over the
phylogenetic tree
so here you see the blue lines uh at the
outset outermost edge
and i'll show you how many isolates we
got for each
asv and here i'm just kind of
highlighting
different species that these isolates
were closely related to so we got a
large
diversity of pseudomonas that we could
culture and many of them
were actually able to inhibit the growth
of at least one of these four pathogens
we also did something similar for flavor
bacteria
and you can see right here is the
phylogenetic tree of the flavor
bacteria and the blue lines again
will show you how many isolates we got
the
asbs that are related to the species
that i'm showing you there for example
the flavor bacterium aquali and that was
also able to inhibit the growth of some
bacteria
and so using this bio full length 16s
rna
based sequencing approach we were able
to identify
a very large number of bacteria in a
very quick way
and and get a real good insight into the
composition
of the microbial communities
and so the biofilm in aquaculture
settings undergo
microbial succession this includes
changes in the species composition
and also an increase in diversity and
this is what one would expect from
biofilms in other environments as well
but this is a real com
complex microbial community
and we also were able to identify
bacteria that were able to inhibit
the growth of other bacteria
and pseudomonas for example is one of
them
and especially pseudomonas was then most
abundant in the biofilms of the race
weight of the youngest fish and so if we
can find
ways perhaps to seed the environment
with pseudomonas or
keep them more abundant we could prevent
the invasion of these biofilms by more
pathogenic bacteria
the full-length 16s rna sequencing and
b4 sequencing
provided yielded different community
structures which might be
probably due to differences in the
primary biases
or also the cell lysis approach
the full length 16s rna sequencing using
the pac bio was a really efficient way
to identify hundreds of isolates in one
big experiment
so instead of doing a whole bunch of
traditional
sanger 16s sequencing having to
align all of these sequences to get a
consensus sequence
consequence and then identify them we
were able to do one big experiment get
full length sequences that are highly
accurate
and identify hundreds of bacteria in one
big
experiment i would like to
acknowledge especially todd testament
stephanie valencia and
and also haley donahue which is not on
this slide yet
was not on this slide yet for really
working on this project and haley did a
really big effort
in culturing these bacteria and
many members of my lab assisted in that
also in idaho we have the help from
stephen rightly and stacy king
this is supported by the usda we worked
with greg wiens and tim welch on this
and shoreline biome was very helpful in
helping us in our analysis
pipeline and mark driscoll was important
in that and eric jackson
was instrumental in doing some of the
data analysis
thank you much and are happy to take any
questions by email